wild money move of the week number one
kevin hart's personal shopper
personal shopper who allegedly bought
1.2 million dollars worth of luxury
items with the comedian's credit cards
gets arrested and appears in court this
is a story from okay magazine okay
kevin hart's personal shopper dylan
sire
appeared in court august 5th
after facing grand larceny charges for
using the actor's credit cards
to buy nearly 1.2 million dollars of
luxury items for his own personal use
let me repeat that yeah use credit cards
to buy 1.2 million dollars of luxury
items with kevin hart's credit cards so
according to the daily mail
the 5-4 comedian superstar who was worth
approximately put his height in there
they put it in there bro he's a little
dude but he's solid that'll have to do
with anything i don't know
not hating he's worth approximately 200
million dollars he hired the 29 year old
back in 2015 right to personally buy
items from if you're kevin hart you're
probably not just going to roll up to
the mall you're going to need a shopper
i get it
but over the years
here's the rub
but over the years the employee
reportedly began to use the cards to
fund a lavish
lifestyle
sire took the credit cards
to stuff cash into his personal accounts
and purchased 1.2 million dollars in
luxury items including a patek philippe
watch multiple watches louis vuitton
bags and a sam friedman painting i guess
that's a pretty big artist
racking up 1.2 million dollars in luxury
items he is charged with grand larceny
criminal possession of stolen property
identity theft and a scheme to defraud
not good things you want to be facing in
court following his arrest the officer
the officers on duty search sire's home
and found approximately 250 grand worth
of cash and luxury goods so that not
only did he put on the credit card he
got some cash out of it too here's the
biggest lesson here here's the biggest
lesson here
don't bite the hand that feeds you yeah
this guy's working for kevin hart we
talked about this on the last segment
cuevo had an assistant the rapper cuevo
an assistant making five g's a day
just pay your dues put in the work
you're working with a guy worth 200
million yeah con artists always get
caught they always do how do you think
you're gonna get away with this how did
you think a million what like did you
not even notice
yeah you're still 20 bucks 200 bucks who
thought all right 1.2 million dollars
bro yeah you're going to jail homie by
the way this is all allegedly by the way
that's the worst thing to have next to
your name allegedly yeah he stole 1.2
it's never allegedly he
donates his time to charity
allegedly he feeds the homeless in his
spare time allegedly he volunteers at
the special olympics it's never that
yeah it's allegedly he committed so and
so crime allegedly he killed i'm not
saying nothing or he donates his time to
you yeah allegedly yeah
so the lesson here
don't bite the hand that feeds you as we
always talk about your net work is your
net worth you're working with freaking
kevin hart one of the biggest comedians
on the planet where 200 million dollars
those connections right could make or
break you now you're ruining a
connection that will ruin you also
you're never getting another job never
going to be anyone's personal shopper
anymore you're done personal shopping
google me bro anyway the bottom line is
criminals always get
caught
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken